i'm bret baer i'm maria bartoromo i'm
brian kilmeade and this is the fox news
rundown
friday february 4th 2022 i'm lisa brady
the president pledges to do more on
crime but his critics say it's just more
words take those actions that would
actually secure this country
and help to get the issue of crime in
the streets back under control we speak
with tennessee republican senator marsha
blackburn
i'm chris foster a fired pro football
coach is suing for racial discrimination
it has all the makings of a very
significant
case but it's only the first step
and i'm dan gainer i've got the final
word on the fox news rundown
[Music]
a day after new york city laid a second
fallen officer to rest president biden
was at police headquarters it's enough
enough is enough because we know we can
do things about this he's appealing for
teamwork to fight crime the federal
government working more closely with
police and communities the answer is not
to abandon our streets that's not the
answer the answer is to come together
police and communities building trust
and making us all safer the answer is
not to defund the police he says
congress should pass more funding for
tools and training including community
violence intervention programs u.s
attorney general merrick garland
traveling with the president justice
department will use every tool at our
disposal to protect our communities
we will hold perpetrators of violent
crime and gun violence accountable but
they did not address concern about bail
reform or some local prosecutors around
the country accused of being soft on
crime new york mayor eric adams who met
with the president thursday is also
placing a heavy emphasis on gun violence
and the trafficking of illegal guns
between states saying earlier this week
when an off-duty officer was shot and
injured over proliferation of guns
ready to use them on individuals in blue
uniforms or blue jeans they don't care
but he has also condemned the recent
release on bond of a repeat offender
accused of shooting at a police officer
one of the things that i really think
gets lost
on the president and some of those on
the left tennessee republican senator
marsha blackburn
they think
that doing
something like this where they are
showcasing
their concern is going to replace
substantial action
that it will be used to kind of deflect
that attention
but i really think they're misreading
the american people especially a lot of
security moms who are out there they're
going to look at this and they're going
to see the president say oh we have to
do something about crime on the street
so we have to get
something done about guns on the streets
and then they're going to say well do it
when people are repeat offenders lock
them up
keep them in jail
make certain that you are dealing with
these issues and don't turn around and
say well we're going to cut bail we're
going to do away with cash bail we're
going to
allow people
to just go back out on the street that
is what people are tired of
they know that there are criminals that
they are repeat offenders uh they're not
being locked up they're being more
lenient with criminals they're being
more lenient with those that have a
record and they're beginning to say oh
no we want something done don't talk to
us show us
there seems to be a bit of a tug of war
between the argument that bail reform is
driving a lot of the crime increase and
those who think it's really more about
guns should there be more of a focus on
both
there should be a focus on bill
reform issues
and uh
this nobel
cash bill
removing cash bill
cutting
the amount of bail that is necessary
this is frustrating to people the other
thing that is frustrating is securing
the southern border the fact that you
have so many gangs
that are coming across that southern
border so taking action
on those things building that wall on
the southern border
prosecuting these criminals that are
coming across the border um
sending them back to their home
countries don't give them a plane ticket
to tennessee or new york or
illinois or kentucky put them on a plane
and send them home
i don't let them come in the country
take those actions that would actually
secure this country
and help to get the issue of crime in
the streets back under control the other
thing to look at these sanctuary cities
and the sanctuary city policies that are
very lenient you have these
organizations that are affiliated with
cartels and gangs that are
headquartering there because they know
law enforcement is going to be more
lenient
is
border security something that your
constituents in tennessee
come to you with as a concern
i hear it every single weekend when i am
home and working and talking with
tennesseans
they see the connection between an open
border
and the drugs that are in the streets
you know i had a and we've got great law
enforcement officers in tennessee that
are working so hard and one of my
sheriffs
last week
made a comment he said marsha you know
we used to
apprehend drugs and it would we would
count it up in grams or ounces he said
today when we do these apprehensions
they're in pounds
and they know
that there's more drugs coming across
the border
before his crime-fighting trip to new
york the president made a big
announcement thursday morning in the
fight against terrorism operating on my
orders
the united states military forces
successfully moved a major terrorist
threat to the world
the global leader of isis when special
operations forces moved in the isis
leader set off explosives killing
himself his wife and his children the
raid was in the planning stages for
months and president biden says it sends
a message to terrorists around the world
could it also send a broader message
about u.s strength at a time when
ukraine is surrounded by russian troops
we always need to salute and be grateful
for our military intelligence operations
which had
located the terrorists followed the
terrorists uh how they worked together
with our troops to make certain that
there was a responsibility a plan to go
in and to take him out we know that
these things do not happen uh quickly
and we also know
that there are months of work that go
into finding a way to carry carry these
operations
out
and we're truly grateful that some of
these special operations forces
with the unique capabilities that they
have are able to work with our military
intelligence units and formulate that
plan and carry forth a successful
operation
would you be hoping that it sends a
message to
you know not just terrorists but perhaps
countries that have
um
aggressive things in mind like russia of
course this this shows that our military
intelligence is working and shows their
capacity
what would help to send
a message to russia with their
aggression and i would say likewise to
iran and china
and north korea all of whom who have
been a bit adventurous
when it comes to expanding their reach
what they need
to see
from the u.s is sanctions that are
properly placed
not only on heads of country but on
financial
interest and oligarchs as in
russia's case
they need to see a diplomatic message
that is coordinated
when you have
weakness or rudderlessness
that is forecast in the statements that
we make it does not do
our country and the cause of freedom
well
the winter olympics underway now in
beijing you've written that we're not
just enabling but participating in evil
by endorsing the chinese communist
party's veneer of diplomacy with these
games who are you hoping
hears that message
when you look at what the chinese
communist party is doing
to the chinese people
it is
horrific
and you can go in and look at what is
happening in hong kong what has been
happening in tibet to the tibetans to
the mongolians you look at the genocide
that is being carried out against the
weakers and what you know is the chinese
communist party and their leadership do
not
care or hold in high regard
the people that make up that country
and
then as you look at the way they're
bullying
taiwan
uh with their threats
the way they are planning during the
olympics to have a meeting between xi
jinping and vladimir putin
and discuss security
issues this is something that should
give everyone
a
a reason
to be apprehensive about what these
countries i call them the axis of evil
new axis of evil
with russia and china and iran and north
korea
i would hope that our allies
will look at this
and will help us stand against this
russian invasion into ukraine
i would hope that it would help our
allies have strength to push back on
china and i hope that
this that we have people here who've
been soft on china who will look at this
and say
now is a time for the us to show our
strength and
our leadership in preserving the cause
of liberty
the president is working on his first
supreme court pick and you'll be part of
those eventual confirmation hearings as
a member of the senate judiciary
committee there has been some debate
about his pledge to choose a black woman
the white house points out president
reagan made the pledge to choose the
court's first woman and he did sandra
day o'connor do you have any concerns
about the president's pledge or the fact
that there's an issue made about any
criticism of it
when i talk to tennesseans they want the
most well qualified person
for the job to be on a federal district
court a federal circuit court and the
u.s supreme court
that is one what they want their
emphasis
to be
and thereby they want me to look at the
nominees the individuals that are
brought forward to question whomever is
the nominee be certain that there are
constitutionalists
that they are going to be there to
support the constitution that they're
going to abide by the rule of law
uh tennesseans do not want to see
activists
on the courts they don't want an
activist judiciary that is trying to
render rulings and opinions and
decisions based on what they would like
the law to be
but they want them to give those rulings
and opinions and decisions based on the
law as written and based on the
constitution is written
tennessee republican senator marsha
blackburn thanks so much for your time
thank you
[Music]
this is dan gainer with your fox news
commentary coming up
brian flores was fired last month after
three seasons as head coach of the miami
dolphins he won 24 games and lost 25 not
great but better than the team had been
playing before he got there flores is
now suing the dolphins the nfl the new
york giants and denver broncos for
racial discrimination he claims he was
brought in for sham interviews with the
giants after his firing and the broncos
in 2019 to fulfill the league's
diversity requirement for interviews
flores said on cbs mornings on wednesday
we didn't have to file a lawsuit for for
the world to know that there's a problem
from a hiring standpoint in regards to
minority coaches in the national
football league the numbers speak for
themselves the national football league
in a statement says the claims in the
suit are without merit it has all the
makings of a very significant
case but it's only the first step
mercedes coleman's founding partner of
the new york offices of the law firm
gordon reese and a fox news legal
analyst but there's litigation is a very
long process
there are documents that have to be
exchanged witnesses that have to be
interviewed
there is going to be lots of
inter just this imaginations of what
litigation process has which has many
steps so it's just the very beginning so
it sure it looks like it's a compelling
case but at the end of the day it's
going to be
really analyze scrutinize and there's so
many steps involved in that process it
won't be until the very final step to
see whether there's any meat on the
bones of this case there's the goal here
to just sort of blow this whole thing
wide open and have the case represent
other minority coaches or candidates who
feel they might have been wrong too
without question that's why he brought a
class action he believes with through
his counsel that there are other
individuals who are similarly situated
as he was it was not given the
opportunities to
manage an nfl team whether it's a head
coach or coordinator
and that's why he's bringing the class
action but this is the very first step
we'll have to see that even if
procedurally
the
fact that it's been identified as a
class action will actually survive there
there are procedural hurdles that a
party has to overcome in order for the
class action to stay
how does brian flores or anybody in a
discrimination case for that matter in
any industry prove that they didn't get
a job or were fired because of their
race and not other reasons related to
competence
there's very various types of evidence
there's direct evidence i have a
conversation that was that i was able to
record because i'm in a one-party state
and all you need is one party consenting
to the recording i've got that that's
direct evidence of discrimination where
someone says you weren't hired because
check the box in this case it's a race
claim
so that's one but there's the second
part is circumstantial evidence which is
what they're trying to establish what
this what flores is trying to establish
through his council is look at the
statistics that the six six are terrible
and they started at the very start of
the of the complaint they start by
saying there's only one of the nfl 32
teams employees of black head coach
there's only four of the nfl 32 teams
employees a black offensive coordinator
only 11 of the nfl teams has a black
defensive coordinator so
it goes on and on about these statistics
but statistics are not the end all and
fall for any of this
you have to peel back the set the third
part of the analysis is what the defense
will start to establish is wait you have
to look at all the individuals that we
interviewed look at the fact that we
have complied with the rooney rule well
part of this lawsuit um regarding the
rooney rule is that flores is claiming
that he had a couple interviews where he
was essentially brought in as a token to
fulfill that you know minimal
requirement with the new york giants and
the denver broncos the giants
there's this text message um that that's
mentioned in the lawsuit do you want to
explain that do you want me to
no i mean it's it's there for those who
have a copy of the complaint you can see
the alleged screenshots of the text
messages between flores and coach bill
pelicek but we don't know in what
context how it was written what was a
conversation there's so many things that
puts that exchange into context that we
don't know at this point all we know is
that
these alleged screenshots of this text
message are in the complaint yeah and at
least this one
what we've seen of it and again without
context is that belichick texted
uh brian flores and basically
congratulated him for getting
the giant's job before he had even
interviewed turns out he texted the
wrong brian the giants ended up um
hiring a different brian
and flores is saying well look this just
proves that my interview
was essentially a sham because they'd
already hired their guy
know and we don't know at this point
chris i mean frank we all we know are
the allegations that have been raised
and the fact that this these screenshots
exist allegedly in this complaint but
we'll have to there's no doubt
bill belichick will be brought in for a
deposition he will have to explain this
exchange he will have to explain what he
knew
it's all about
we're talking about a
bill belichick's understanding of who
was the incoming head coach
but unless he was the decision maker and
he knew exactly what was taking place
with the hiring of the head coach and
the interviewing of brian flores we
don't really know yeah bill belgic of
course the coach of the new england
patriots not involved
in any way here but belichick obviously
knows people with the giants and maybe
had some inside information the giants
and the broncos
um dispute these claims they say that
brian flores was a strongly considered
candidate until the very end um
and i suppose they that they can find
ways to prove that
and they can what they'll end up doing
is everybody involved in the interview
of brian flores will have to have to
have
their statement under oath through a
deposition and they'll have to explain
exactly what how it took place how brian
flores ended up even being selected for
the interview who was involved in the
inter in the interview process who was
involved in the decision-making process
i mean they're so
this is just a web of information that
needs to be picked up one strand at a
time
another part of this initial salvo uh
doesn't have any discrimination but it
could really have implications if if
it's proven true the this accusation
that the miami dolphins owner flores was
the coach of the dolphins for the last
couple of seasons before being fired
last month
he accuses steven ross of when he hired
him in 2019 of offering him an extra
hundred thousand dollars per loss
to tank the season on purpose to get a
better draft pick you know ross maybe
thought the team wasn't going anywhere
anyway so let's just be all out bad
so there are you know there are these
competitive
questions
uh ross vehemently denies that are there
criminal implications if flores can
prove it
uh maybe lawsuits from fans or gamblers
and and does ross potentially have a
case for defamation oh without question
i mean if if but let me just say
let me put this all in context if all
the accusations about this hundred
thousand dollar alleged payoff exists
only in this complaint
there is what's called a qualified
privilege so therefore steve ross does
not have a defamation case because the
allegations of this payment only reside
within the the body of the complaint
but if there's evidence that some uh
outside of the context of this complaint
that these accusations are being made
against steve ross then yes he
potentially has a defamation case
against flores yeah if it exists now it
only exists in the complaint so this
qualified privilege would attach and
then he could not
that's not to say he won't try certainly
it's a compelling argument to try to
make a defamation case it's just they
may be met with a motion to dismiss for
the qualified privilege i've just
mentioned
now the rooney rule where you have to
interview
you know a couple of minority candidates
for for head coach and other leadership
positions do you have any other industry
with a codified rule like that and do
they do they work
they
they don't there are i'm not familiar if
there are any codified rules per se i
know that there is a rule in california
that requires boards to be diversified
with females to be added to the board
but that's in california i'm not very
familiar with that law i just know
anecdotally that there is a law that
exists about
about bringing in uh females into boards
for california businesses so there are
other rules that exist and perhaps other
mandates that exist around around the
country but it really boils down to a
genuine authentic commitment to
diversity inclusion of any company
and whether it is an nfl team or it's a
fortune 500 company it really boils down
to what's whether it's authentic and a
true commitment and we've seen
that especially as a defense attorney
that i represent a lot of companies
around the country
they do have that genuine interest to
bring diversity inclusion to the
forefront of their companies and they
have made significant strides to do so
and it's not that they were required to
but they just knew it was it was good
business to do so it gives you different
thought processes it gives you a a
different thought process in your in
your board it it actually impacts the
bottom line companies that do embrace
diversity inclusion
have a an increase to their bottom line
so there's a good business reasons to
embrace the diversity inclusion and
without made over overarching commitment
because there is some mandate rule that
exists
just finally brian flores says he
doesn't care about his own career
anymore he's doing this
for the next generation um what if you
were gonna crystal ball it let's say
everything he says turns out to be true
or mostly true
what could happen here with the national
football league well i mean if if
mr flores is able to establish
everything he said obviously as i said
this is the first step it is it is just
the first step in a slew of many steps
to come to see whether or not he can
actually succeed at the end of the day
the changes could be they could be
implicated in terms of there could be
consent decrees i know that there's a
another case that's going to be filed
it's actually mentioned in the complaint
they're going to file a charge at the
equal employment opportunity commission
in that administrative charge there can
actually be a consent decree that will
control the nfl and the processes for a
period of time so there there might be
an actual consent decree that controls
the processes from the future there may
be if there's a jury trial in this case
there may be punitive damages that that
are then lodged against the nfl if the
class action survives and i said that
there are a lot of hurdles that need to
be that need to be overcome in order for
the class to actually continue and exist
as a class
instead of multiple cases of individuals
who are who allegedly faced the same
discrimination that mr flores claims to
have to have endured
so there are many different scenarios
that can happen
but
we'll have to see where it goes because
i said there are a lot of moving parts
and there are a lot of different avenues
that can occur but all of those can
happen punitive damages consent decrees
only of course if mr flores is
successful in bringing his claims to
bear and establishing the evidence that
needs to be done
mercedes coleman founding partner of the
new york offices of gordon and rei senda
of course she's a fox news legal analyst
mercedes thanks for coming on today
my pleasure thanks chris
[Music]
getting schooled is a podcast hosted by
fox nation's abby hornacek each week
abby and her expert guests tackle topics
we take for granted and help explain the
roots and meanings behind them subscribe
and listen now by going to
foxnewspodcasts.com
america is listening to fox news
subscribe to this podcast at
foxnewspodcasts.com
and now some good news with tanya j
powers
[Music]
getting too close to secure areas at the
pentagon is a no-no but a recent
intruder who crossed the line couldn't
have known that
a loose hen was found one morning this
week near the department of defense
headquarters and the animal welfare
league of arlington virginia posted
about the incident on social media they
weren't at liberty to say exactly where
the hen a rhode island red with brown
feathers and a red comb was found but
they could only say it was at a security
checkpoint it's also not clear just how
the chicken got there in the first place
the bird was described as sweet and
nervous and did allow some people to pet
her she's even been given a name henny
penny the same moniker of the chicken
that thinks the sky is falling in the
folk tale
penny is doing okay now she was adopted
by an animal league staff member who has
a farm in western virginia the group
couldn't resist a little humor in their
social media posts saying quote
apparently the answer to why did the
chicken cross the road is to get to the
pentagon
you knew that was coming right
tonya jai powers fox news
[Music]
it's time for your fox news commentary
dan gainer
what's on your mind
jeff zucker's time leading cnn include
these five truly shocking moments cnn
president jeff zucker resigned on
wednesday for failing to disclose a
consensual relationship with an employee
but what's truly amazing is that the
long line of scandals and embarrassing
moments during zucker's tenure didn't
force him out earlier
nearly a decade with zucker at the helm
transformed cnn from a liberal news
outlet to a blatant tool for leftist
politics here are five truly memorable
aspects of zucker's time leading cnn one
of the most unethical aspects of
zucker's time as cnn's boss might also
have been his undoing zucker allowed
then anchor chris cuomo to lead the
network's effort to promote chris's
brother andrew then new york governor
the dynamic duo made headlines together
as chris yucked it up with andrew joking
about covet 19 testing as americans died
by the thousands first andrew was
implicated in numerous sexual harassment
allegations costing him his job then it
was uncovered that chris had been
instrumental in his brother's defense
effort even carrying dirt on the
accusers cnn media reporter brian
stelter raised the possibility that
chris cuomo might have set the departure
in motion
two 2020 black lives matter anti-far
rights did billions of dollars in damage
roughly two dozen people killed
businesses looted and burned and none of
that was the enduring image of rioting
instead it was a simple bit of cnn
propaganda that defined both the
protests and the bias media coverage the
chiron or words that appeared on screen
was written in all caps as fires burned
behind the reporter quote fiery but
mostly peaceful protests after police
shooting
in a year when journalists went out of
their way to pretend riots never
happened that chiron became a rallying
cry for cnn critics
three then white house correspondent jim
acosta was the angry face of cnn
throughout the trump administration he
harangued lectured and got in fights
with the president and his staff in one
memorable dust-up acosta refused to give
up the microphone trump let him have it
with both barrels honestly i think you
should let me run the country you run
cnn and if you did it well your ratings
would be much higher
four zucker didn't hire don lemon as
anchor but he kept him around after a
parade of gaffs and embarrassing moments
even after lemon suggested the malaysian
jet islander might have been sucked up
by a black hole
lemon evolved to take race baiting to
new lows
last january said if you voted for trump
you voted for who the clan supported you
voted for the person who nazi's support
you voted for the person who the
alt-right supports that's the crowd you
were in
and that's jeff zucker's legacy
number five no list of cnn
embarrassments would be complete without
creepy porn lawyer michael avenatti cnn
gave avenatti 122 appearances to push
his rants against trump
the pr bullets got so ridiculous that
media maven stelter predicted avenatti
was a potential 2024 democrat
presidential candidate this has been dan
gainer with the media research center
you've been listening to the fox news
rundown stay up to date by subscribing
to this podcast at
foxnewspodcasts.com and for up to the
minute news go to foxnews.com
[Music]
download and subscribe to original
podcast from fox news radio it's time to
get caught up on what's happened and
what's next i'm jared halpern from
washington subscribe and listen now by
going to foxnewspodcast.com
love fox news click the subscribe button
to get more of the news and opinion you
trust and click the fox news rundown
playlist for the latest episodes